نستكمل واياكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه
للاحداث الجاريه في السودان حيث الالتزام
بالهدنه وانما تبادل الالتهامات بمن يخترق
هذه الهدنه بينما ارتفع عدد القتلى الى
اكثر من 300 شخص ونحو 1600 جريح حتى الان
وفقا لارقام امميه طبعا فيما ارتفعت
المخاوف من الزياده الاوضاع الانسانيه
سوءا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع في السودان اليوم
الموافقه على هدنه جديده لمده 24 ساعه
تبدا من الساعه السادسه بتوقيت المحلي من
مساء اليوم وحتى السادسه من مساء غد
الخميس هذا واكدت قوات الدعم السريع في
البيان الالتزام التام بوقف كامل لاطلاق
النار معبره عن املها في التزام الطرف
الاخر بالهدنه حسب التوقيت المعلن هذا
وكان الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وافقه امس
الثلاثاء على هدنه انسانيه لمده 24 ساعه
لفتح مسارات امنه لعبور المدنيين غير ان
الجانبين تبادل الاتهامات بانتهاكهم
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع النقل الجنود
المصريين الذين كانوا في مطار مروي عند
بدل اشتباكات الى العاصمه الخرطوم وقالت
قوات الدعم السريع ان جميع الجنود
المصريين بخير ويتلقون الرعايه اللازمه
وسيتم تسليمهم متى سنحت الفرصه المناسبه
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع واياكم هذه
الصور المباشره من الخرطوم عمليه الاشتباك
ما زالت قائمه ومندلعه بين الطرفين والتي
بدات قبل ايام حتى الساعه بالرغم من كل
الهدن التي اتفق عليها لم يلتزم اي من
طرفي النزاع باي هدنه من هذه الهدن وطبعا
الاشتباكات ما زالت قائمه خصوصا بمحيط مقر
القياده العامه بسبب يعني سعي الطرفين
للسيطره على هذه النقطه التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه لمسار النزاع بين كل من قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني طبعا
كمان نستمع يعني اطلق نار كثيف واستخدام
لاسلحه ثقيله لم تهدا هي طبعا متقطعه بين
الوقت والاخر ولكنها لكن الوتيره لم تهدا
والاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره
من القاهره مشاهدينا تنضم الينا الصحفيه
المختصه في شان الافريقي صباح موسى للحديث
اكثر عن مجريات النزاع في الخرطوم اهلا
وسهلا بك سيده صباح يعني اليوم فرص
التسويه بين الطرفين صعبه جدا لبل يمكن
القول بانها مستحيله بسبب يعني رفض
الطرفين الذهاب الى اي تسويه او حوار قبل
حسم اي شيء على الارض بظل المعطيات
الموجوده
اذا مشاهدينا كما نستمع يعني اشتدت
الاشتباكات وايضا اطلاق النار الكثيف بين
الطرفين وهو ما يحصل يوميا خصوصا عندما
ناتي يعني الى ختام النهار ومع الدخول
بساعات الليل
اذا هذه الاشتباكات التي لم تهدا يعني
ياتي هذا
التصعيد الان واستمرار استخدام الاسلحه
الثقيله
والرشاشات ومضادات يعني المدفعيات بعد
سيطره الجيش على
مقاعده مروي ومطار مروي التي تعتبر
استراتيجيه وكان القتال دائر نحوها منذ
بدايه
المواجهه بين الطرفين وحتى اليوم وطبعا
ايضا بالامس تبعنا سيطره الجيش على قاعده
الابيض التي ايضا تعتبر نقطه استراتيجيه
كنا نتحدث عن ثلاث نقاط استراتيجيه الابيض
قاعده مروي والقاعده
الموجوده بالخرطوم والتي الان الاشتباكات
دائره حول الجيش حسن اول قاعدتين الابيض
والمراوي الان القتال يعني شرس
بمحيط القاعده الثالثه
اذا سنبقي الصوت مشاهدينا واعود يعني فورا
تصعيد في حال يعني ترى اي تصعيد بين
الطرفين سانتقل الى القاهره مجددا
والصحافيه المختصه في شان الافريقي صباح
موسى سيده صباح يعني سابدا مع النقطه التي
كنت اتحدث عنها ثلاث نقاط استراتيجيه
الجيش حسن اثنين منها اليوم القتال محصور
بشكل اساسي بمحيط القاعده العسكريه
بالخرطوم اذا ما حسمها الجيش الى اين
سيتحول الصراع خصوصا ان هذه الازمه لا
رابح وخاسر فيها حتى وانسحبت دعم السريع
من داخل من داخل الخرطوم سيكون هناك يعني
حرب بمناطق اخرى وسينسحب الى مناطق اخرى
وتبقى يعني دائره النزاع مفتوحه
بالتاكيد هدف الدعم السريع لو تلاحظين كل
الهجوم مركز على محيط القياده العامه يعني
محيط القياده العامه اعتقد انه اصبح هدف
استيراد تيجي لقواته طبعا بالتاكيد الجيش
محصن هذه هي قياده الجيش في الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع تتوجه الان المعلومات
الوارده من الخرطوم ان تكثيف الطلقات
والضرب على القصر ومحيط القياده العامه
منذ بدايه الاشتباكات كانت القياده العامه
هي اكثر مكان استراتيجي يستهدفه الدعم
السريع لو سقطت القياده العامه معناه ان
الجيش سقط في هذه
الجوله من الحرب وربما يستطيع الدعم
السريع ولذلك هو يركز ان ما يدخل ويخرج
الى البلاد يعني نتحدث عن 95% هو بمحيط
هذه القاعده بمطار الخرطوم ومن هنا
الاهميه الكبرى يعني لهذه النقطه بالذات
هذه النقطه لانها قياده الجيش
كوريا بالتالي هي رمز كبير لسقوط الدوله
حتى القصر وبيت الضيافه اعتقد رمزياتهم
اقل لانه اصلا السودان لم يكن يحكم حتى من
القصر في الفتره الانتقاليه اعتقد ان كل
كل شيء من كان يسيطر من خلال من القياده
وبالتالي محيط القياده هو هدف استراتيجي
للدعم السريع ياتون من كل الاتجاهات من
الجهات الشرقيه والغربيه يحاولون كرا وفرا
يعاودون الكره لاحظتم منذ بدايه
الاشتباكات انها تشتد مع قرب الافطار
والصحيح معنى انه قد يكون بعض القوات
المسلحه
الجنود يريدون الافطار اعتقد ان الدعم
السريع يزيد من ذلك
شهود عيان في الشوارع في الخرطوم ابلغونا
بان جنود الدعم السريع في نهار رمضان لم
غالبيتهم لم يصوموا قد ياخذوا رخصه او
انهم في طبيعتهم لا يصوموا
لكن اعتقد انهم يريدون مع قرب الافطار
تزداد الهجمات كانت هذه ملحوظه ولذلك
ستجدين تركيز مع قرب اذان المغرب تركيز
الطلقات عاليه جدا
في حال سيطره يعني اليوم الجيش لن يخرج من
هذه المعركه قبل ان يحسمها لان يعني سقوط
اي شيء بيد الدعم السريع يعني تحول
الدراماتيكي بالمشهد العسكري داخل البلاد
في حال يعني حسب المعركه قرب القياده
العامه ستنسحب قوات الدعم السريع وستتمركز
بمناطق اخرى ان كان خارج الخرطوم ماذا
يعني هذا على خارطه الصراع داخل السودان
لو كنت تقصدين ان الدعم السريع سيسيطر على
القياده العامه دي في البدايه هيكون لها
رمزيه جدا لا لا اذا الجيش حسن حسن
لو حسن طيب هذا السيناريو وارد ايضا طبعا
العاصمه
يعني لم اعلم من الذي اختارها ميدان
للقتال في هذا التوقيت اعتقد ان الدعم
السريع اختارها لانه
الجيش من التاكيد بالتاكيد في القتال
سيتروى كثيرا وقت الضربات لم يستطع ضرب
الطيران في العاصمه لو كانت في اماكن
متطرفه كانت من الممكن ان تكون الحرب
مفتوحه لكن هنا التزام نظامي اعتقد من
القوات المسلحه الجيش الدعم السريع يكر
ويفر في هذه المعركه لذلك لا لن لا نرى من
المسيطر عليها ولن سيهجم ينتصر وبعد دقيقه
التي نسمعها الان فلنسمع الى صوت الطبيعي
نستمع مشاهدينا
اذا استخدام كثيف للاسلحه الثقيله
ومواجهات
دائره بين الطرفين بين كل من الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني بعد قبل حوالي 40 دقيقه
من مهله ومن هدنه جديده من المفترض ان
يلتزم بها الطرف
من الخرطوم ما ينضم الي مشاهدينا عبر
الهاتف اسامه احمد الناشط السياسي اسامه
يعني مع الامل ان يلتزم الطرفان بهذه
الهدنه قبل حوالي الاربعين دقيقه كيف هي
الصوره من هناك يعني
باي منطقه انت الان وما هي الاصوات التي
تسمعها
نعم انا في منطقه الخرطوم في منطقه الرياض
والان قياده تكون الاشتباكات منحصه
في المحيط القياده العامه
وبقيه احياء الخرطوم
هل ترصدون اي تحرك لقوات عسكريه ان كان من
الجيش او الدعم السريع بشوارع المدينه
بهذه الاثناء
او قبل قليل
لا يوجد اي مظاهر اي تحركات عسكريه في
الشوارع وعمومه المواطنين لا يتحركون عبر
الشوارع الكريات وانما يتحركون هذا
الاحياء
وعبر الاحياء لا يوجد اي مظاهر لاي تواجد
عسكري من الطرفين
وانما نسمع الاصوات
ونسمع الضرب من الناحيه القياده العامه
فيبدو انه حصلت المعارض في منطقه معينه
وهي منطقه القياده ووسط الخرطوم
وانما بقيه الاحياء تجاه نسبيا وبعض
السكون الان
بسعه النهار هل رصدتم اي عمليات حشد لقوات
من قبل الطرفين الى محيط القياده العامه
لا لا يمكن لك التحرك في اتجاه الطرق
العامه حتى ترصدي من يتحرض فالمواطنين
دائما
محصورين في احيائهم
يعني داخل الاحياء الناس تتحرك وتذهب الى
البقالات
والمخابز وكذا لكن ما فيش تحرك من ناحيه
الطرق العامه الكبرى حتى يتم رصد التحركات
العسكريه من الصعب التكاهم باي تحركات
عسكريه لانها توجد دائما في الطرق
الرئيسيه والمناطق
معي لو سمحت ساعود اليك خلال هذه التغطيه
مشاهدينا سينضم الي الان من جنوب الخرطوم
الصحافي متدثر محمد احمد للحديث عن هذه
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الطرفين استاذ
يعني للمفارقه بانه منذ استقلال السودان
لم تشهد العاصمه قبل ان ان اسال هل يمكن
ان تنقل لي صوره من المكان الذي انت موجود
فيه كيف هي كيف هو الوضع هناك هل هناك
يعني حشد لاي قوات من قبل الطرفين للذهاب
نحو العاصمه
منذ مساء الامر ولكن الان الاشتراكات في
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم في منطقه
قبل قليل ان هناك اشتباكات
بين القوات المسلحه
وفصيل من الدعم السريع في منطقه
حجم هذا الاشتباك ومدى
سينتهي او مد
او متى
سيصل الى نهايته
لا احد يفيد ذلك ولكن
المنطقه
بكافه الاسلحه التي
يعني من الرشاشات ثقيله ورشاشات خفيفه هنا
في منطقه جنوب
الخطه اصبحت منذ صباح اليوم مع مع هذه
الجمله المؤقته الى بين الحين
والاخر وجوح
ج المواطنين الذين يودون الخروج من منطقه
الخرطوم او منطقه ولايه الخرطوم بصوره
عامه الى بقيه الولايات السودان الى
الولايات الجنوبيه من هناك هل عمليه
انتقال المواطنين يعني ايضا حتى زملائنا
الموجودين هناك بالخرطوم يحاولون اجلاء
عائلاتهم الى خارج العاصمه عمليه الاجلاء
والنزوح الى خارج العاصمه هل هي سهله بظل
القصف بظل المواجهات الدائره بعدد كبير من
النقاط
نعم بحسب ما تحدثنا الى الى الى عدد من
الذين يعني اتوا من الولايات هذا يعني بعض
المركبات او بعض سيتم مركبات الذين اتوا
من الولايات الى الخرطوم لنقل الذين يودون
الذهاب الى الولايات مره
اخرى ان هناك بعض النقاط
قوات الدعم السريع لكن لا يوجد يعني لا
يوجد اعتراض بهذه العربات او لهذه
السيارات او لهذه الرحلات التي تمضي من
الخرطوم الى الولايه ولكن النقاط او
النقاط الارتكاز يوجد بها دعنا نستمع لو
سمحت استاذ الى الى الصوت الطبيعي واعود
اليك
اذا مشاهدينا كما نتابع يعني تصاعد كثيف
للنيران بهذه الاثناء قبل حوالي الاربعين
دقيقه من الهدنه المعلنه بين الطرفين
الصوره نفسها اعيد واكرر بالامس تصاعد
كثيف للدخان اطلاق مواجهات كثيفه استخدام
للاسلحه الثقيله قبل الهدنه ولكنها طبعا
لم يلتزموا بالهدنه بالامس اليوم العين
على هذه الهدنه التي يهدنا بمنحها انساني
كبير لمحاوله ايصال مساعدات طبيه انسانيه
للسكان الذين يعتبرون محاصرين داخل احياء
العاصمه في الخرطوم وطبعا ايضا ممكن ان
تفتح المجال امام اي محادثات او محاوله
لخرق الجمود الحاصل اليوم بين الطرفين بين
كل من قوات الدعم السريع وكل من الجيش
السوداني الذي يعني الساعه يرفضون اي حوار
او اي هدنه حقيقيه تؤسس الى مخرج لهذا
الاقتتال الداخلي اعود اليك استاذ اسامه
يعني اليوم الحرب الدائره بوسط السودان
بالعاصمه تحديدا بالخرطوم لم تشهدها
البلاد منذ استقلال البلاد كل الحروب كانت
تكون اما بالجنوب او الغرب او الشرق يعني
ان مداخل العاصمه هي المره الاولى ماذا
يعني ذلك على الوقت الحالي على مستقبل
البلاد
والله اشوف الوضع الان الوضع غامض
والمواطن السوداني اللي انا قتله ولا جمل
فيما يجري وهو مغلوب على امره
[موسيقى]
اليوم
ولا يعرف المواطن السوداني البسيط لماذا
يتقاتلون ولا يعرف المواطن ما هي سبب
الحرب
والان الشعب السوداني يعيش مرتاحه حقيقيه
والان بدات
الكهرباء تنقطع من معظم الاحياء في
العاصمه والمياه
واربح الجميع يفكر في في المغادره
وهذه تجربه جديده على على الاقل على على
الشعب الشعب السوداني يعني على المواطنين
في مدينه الخرطوم
ا ان النزوح كان عاده ما يكون من الاطراف
وليس من داخل العاصمه اليوم الان الن
زوحها بالعاصمه والى الاقاليم يعني الان
في المنطقه التي اسكن فيها انا في حي
الرياض قريب من شارع شارع الطريق مدني
فكل الاسر الان تحمل الاسر والعربات
والسيارات
[موسيقى]
وبيهاجروا الى الاقاليم المجاوره خصوصا
اقليم الجزيره ومدنيه
نعم دعنا نستمع استاذ عادل لو سمحت الصوت
الطبيعي للاشتباكات واعود الى ضيوفي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا انتقل الى اسامه ابو بكر
والمتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر
استاذ اسامه كيف هي الصوره الان من
الخرطوم بعد يعني كل هذه الاشتباكات
العنيفه التي لم تهدا
عن كم عدد نتحدث اصابات كيف هو حال
المواطنين خصوصا ان هناك نقص بالمواد
الغذائيه بالمواد الطبيه والاستشفاء
وغيرها
طيب بصفته اول حاجه انا اسامه ابو بكر
المسؤول الاعلان في الهلال الاحمر
السوداني نحن بنتكلم عن
النشاطات التي قبلها الهلال الاحمر
السوداني وتقييمنا للوضع الصحي الحالي
الموجود والوضع الانساني بشكل عام اول
حاجه نحن ما عندنا رقم محدد لعدد الذين
توفوا من بدايه الاحداث يوم السبت الماضي
او عدد المصابين بشكل عام
بنعتمد دائما على احصائيات البناء نحن لكن
ما في دلوقتي جهه معينه على الاطلاق في
الدوله عند احصائيه دقيقه 100% نسبه
الاتساع الرقعه الجغرافيه للمصابين في
منطقه الخرطوم طيب عشان نكون فاهمين الوضع
اكثر
ولايه الخرطوم
ولايه ضخمه جدا اللي هي العاصمه
العاصمه بتاعه السودان فيها سبعه محليات
او سبعه
مقاطعات ضمن ضمن الولايه
وبيقتنوها تقريبا ربع سكان السودان اكثر
من 12 مليون نسمه
طيب
تفضلي
بحركه النزوح يعني كنا نتابع مع الزملاء
هناك وايضا مع ضيوفنا ان هناك حركه نزوح
كبيره من المنطقه الداخليه من العاصمه الى
الاطراف اعود اليك استاذ ابو بكر
اي نعم نحن طبعا المنظمات الانسانيه
بالتحديد نحن بنتكلم عن الهلال الاحمر
السوداني واللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
والاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات الصليب والهلال
احمد الثلاثه في منظومه واحده كلنا متفقين
على انه ما لم يتم اعلان
والاتفاق بين الطرفين وبمباركات دوليه على
مسارات امنه لاخلاء المصابين وتمهيدا
للنقلهم للمستشفيات وحتى المسارات الامنه
دي بتخلي انه يتم نقل لادويه ومعينات طبيه
للنهوض بالمستشفيات هي واحده من الازمات
الازمات هي مشكله شنو ان المستشفيات ما
فيها معينات طبيه لكن حتى اذا في في مناطق
معينه ايصال هذه المعينات الى المستشفيات
ابغى معي استاذ ابو بكر لو سمحت ساعود
اليك مشاهدينا تنضم الينا من نيروبي
كو المتحدثه الرسميه
للجنه الصليب الاحمر في افريقيا قبل ان
ابدا معك يا سيده ايلونه مشاهدينا ساتابع
واياكم هذه الصور لاطلاق نار قربه مستشفى
في الخرطوم اذا فلنستمع لصوت الطبيعي
واعود
كلنا مع بعض
ايوه
اقعد مشاهدينا الى المتحدثة الرسميه
للجنه الصليب الاحمر في افريقيا استاذه
اليمنى يعني بدايه كيف هي الصوره
الانسانيه من هناك وهل تواصلتم مع طرفي
النزاع لفتح ممر انساني خلال الهدنه خصوصا
وان الوضع الانساني او الصحي متردد جدا
هناك
[تصفيق]
وتزداد الامور سوءا مع مرور ساعات في ظل
استمرار العمليات القتاليه كنا نهيب
باستمرار
بفتح مسارات انسانيه من اجل تقديم المؤن
والوصول الى المستشفيات ومساعدتهم على
اعاده خطوط المياه والكهرباء
وكنا نفعل هذا الامر من خلال حوارات
ثنائيه ومن خلال الدبلوماسيه الانسانيه
لان الامر قد اصبح اكثر والحاحا ولا
نستطيع ان نشدد ما فيه الكفايه على اهميه
الضروره الوصول الى المستشفيات وسيارات
الاسعاف لاخلاء المصابين والجرحى
وكذلك لجمع الجثث التي لا تزال ام القاتل
في الطرقات منذ عده ايام
سي يعني كنا كنا نتابع قبل قليل الصور من
المستشفيات الواقع ماساوي وايضا يعني ما
رفضناه مع كل الزملاء هناك بان هناك نقص
فادح على مستوى الادويه على مستوى تامين
الاسعافات الاوليه والجثث مرميه يعني في
الشوارع والمستشفيات كيف
ستتعاملون مع هذا الواقع وكيف ستضغطون على
طرفي النزاع لتامين ممرات ولتامين وصول
الامدادات الصحيه اللازمه
وقبل كل شيء اننا بحاجه لقدره الوصول
ونفعل كل ما هو بوسعنا على كافه المستويات
من خلال الاجتماعات والمناقشات في الخرطوم
وفي اماكن اخرى
وتفعيل كل قناه ممكنه والسبيل ممكن من اجل
تامين الممرات الانسانيه من اجل ايصال
المساعدات التوقف في العمليه القتاليه ليس
من اجلنا بل من اجل المدنيين الذين لا
زالوا عالقين منذ خمسه ايام وقد نفدت منهم
المياه والمواد الغذائيه الوضع لا يمكن
تحمله وهذا التزام بموجب القانون الانساني
الدولي لكافه هؤلاء الاطراف المتحاربه ان
يعملوا على تامين هذا الحيز الانساني هو
ان يعملوا على معامله وان يعملوا على
تقديم المعامله اللائقه الانسانيه
للاسرى
وبالنسبه لنا فنحن عبرنا عن استعدادنا
لتقديم الدعم
وهناك متطوعون من الهلال الاحمر السوداني
الذين عبروا عن عدم مقدرهم للتحرك بسبب
اطلاق الرصاص في كل مكان يعني كنتم قد
اعربتم باكثر من بيان وباكثر من تصريح عن
عدم قدره الكوادر الامميه من التنقل داخل
شوارع الخرطوم وايضا بمناطق النزاع بسبب
النزاع الدائر اليوم يعني هل هناك امل
باستجابه من قبل الطرفين هل هناك تواصل
مباشر معهم يعني لاعلاء الشان الانساني عن
اي شان اخر
يجب عليهم فعله لان لان هناك حاجه انسانيه
ملحه ولا بدل الاطراف في المتحاربه ان
تنظر بهذه الحاجه بهذه بهذه الحاجه
الانسانيه لانها التزاما بموجب القانون
الانساني الدولي وجزء من اتفاقيه جنيف
ونحن بدورنا مستمرين في
مناشدتي كافه الاطراف بصفه منظمه انسانيه
وبقدر ما نستطيع ان نفعله هو ان نستمر في
الطلب والحاحيه على الوضع الانساني
الماساوي هناك وبمجرد حصولنا على قدره
للوصول سوف نتصرف من اجل الاستجابه
للاحتياجات هناك
السيده
المواد الطبيه خصوصا بعدما خرج العديد من
المستشفيات عن الخدمه
في الصعود واخر تحديدات رايناها عندما
تحدثنا عن عدد الوفيات
فالرقم يفوق 200 شخص وعندما نتحدث عن
الجرحى فان الرقم اكثر من الف شخص هو
بالنسبه للجثث
متزايده وقد يصعب علينا بشد ان نعطيكم
صوره دقيقه للوضع الانساني الان لاننا لن
نستطيع التحرك بحريه بالنسبه لنا وليتسنى
لنا التقييم الموقف
ومعرفه الارقام الدقيقه لابد لنا من
الوصول الى تلك الاماكن وفي هذه المرحله
يتعذر علينا فعل ذلك ولكن ما نراه ونسمعه
ان الوضع ما زال مستمرا في الاتجاه نحو
وصوره ماساويه وهناك اشخاص مفقودين وهذا
سؤال جيد للتحدث عنهم لان كافتها تلك
الجثث المرميه في الطرقات ما لم نعمل على
على تامين ازالتها بطريقه
تكرم وفات هؤلاء الاشخاص فان هناك واقع
ملح وهناك سنوات ايضا عاشها السودان ايضا
حتى مع الظل عن العمليات القتاليه التي
تدور هناك
ابقي معي السيده اليونا ساعود اليك اعود
مجددا مشاهدينا الى اسامه ابو بكر المسؤول
الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني استاذ
اسامه يعني استمعنا الى الصليب الاحمر
الذي تحدثت فيها المسؤوله الاعلاميه
بافريقيا عن التعاون الموجود مع الهلال
الاحمر السوداني هل اليوم التواصل بين
الفريقين والتعاون على الارض سهل او
قادرين على اتمام بشكل على الاقل يعني
مبدئي بظل كل الطرق المقطوعه بظل كل
الصراع الدائر
طبعا نحن بنتعاون تعاون وثيق جدا مع
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر صحيح يعني
مش لجنه الدوليه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر موجود عندها بيعته في السودان
وادوانا
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر عندها بيحسب في
السودان في الخرطوم وفي في مدن كثيره يعني
متاثره بالنزاع المسلح
والهلال الاحمر السوداني موجود نحن بنشتغل
بتنسيق مع بعض تنسيق محكم لسبب لانه
تقليديا
ما يحدث في الخرطومه الان منذ السبت
الماضي عباره عن نزاع مسلح بين قوتين
النزاع المسلح ده محكوم باتفاقيات دوليه
اللي هي اسمها اتفاقيه الاضافيه يعني يلا
ده المجال بتعامل اللجنه الدوليه ونحن
كاهلال احمد سوداني كجمعيه الوطنيه بمساعد
في الاعمال دي طيب نحن نفس الحكايه هي
اللي قالتها اليونا كل الناس كل حتى نحن
المنظمات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر هي
المشكله في اتفاق على
مسارات انسانيه امنه مسارات دي حنعمل فيها
ايه حنجمع فيها الجسم اريد
المعينات الطبيه للمستشفيات حنخلي فيها
الناس المحتجزين في الاماكن الموجوده
يتفق عليها طرفيا النزاع
ما حنقدر نعمل اي حاجه لانه
ابو بكر اعود اليك سيده اليونا يعني كنتم
قد استعرضتم ويعني ونشدتم باكثر من بيان
ان كان انتم او المنظمه الصحه العالميه او
منظمات اخرى اماميه عن تعرض
العاملين
داخل الاراضي السودانيه ان كان بعضهم طبعا
توفي نتيجه الهجمات التي تعرضوا لها
والبعض الاخر محاصر هل لديكم اي فرق
موجوده داخل الخرطوم او مناطق النزاع
محاصره او غير قادره على الخروج او لديكم
خسائر بشريه هناك
لا يوجد اي من موظفين فقد حياته هناك
بالنسبه للعاملين في الخرطوم وفي اماكن
اخرى في السودان التي يوجد لدينا فيها
مكاتب وكذلك ايضا في المناطق التي كان
هناك فيها عمليات قتال
مستمر ولكن لا توجد لديهم قدره لتحرك
مكاتبنا في الخرطوم على مقربه من المطار
والمطار كما تعلمون في الخرطوم هو على
قريب من المناطق السكنيه التي
تستعر فيها العمليات القتاليه ولدها
فالوضع صعب للغايه بالنسبه لموظفينا هناك
لكن من حزن الحظ لا يوجد اي من زملائنا
الذين قضوا في هذه المعارك استاذه اليوم
يعني كل المرافق الصحيه تعرضت لكثير من
الهجمات وهو يعني ما يعنيه من انتهاك
للقانون الانساني الدولي بحسب ما هو معلوم
وفقا للقوانين الدوليه هل ستتحركون مع
المنظمات الدوليه مع منظمه الصحه العالميه
بهذا الاطار خصوصا ان في حال لم يكون هناك
تحرك جدي وهدن انسانيه سنذهب الى انهيار
تام للنظام الصحي السوداني مع ما يعنيه من
كارثه انسانيه
اليوم من زملائي من من جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر السوداني اليوم وعندما سمعته كلمات
تلك
ابقوا معي ضيوفي لو سمحتوا مشاهدينا اذا
كما نتابع ما زال اطلاق النار الكثيف يعني
نسمعه بكل وضوح داخل الخرطوم نحن امام
يعني تبقى سبع دقائق قبل الدخول بالهدنه
المعلنه كما بالامس اذا من المتوقع ان
ندخل تمام الساعه الثامنه الان بتوقيت
المحلي هنا
بين الطرفين يجب ان تستمر ل 24 ساعه هذه
الصور المباشره الخاصه بقناه العربيه تنقل
لنا الصراع والاشتباك الذي والمواجهات
التي ما زالت دائره حتى الساعه طبعا اعمده
الدخان الكثيف تتصاعد بهذه الاثناء كما
بالامس هي الصوره نفسها قبل الدخول
بالهدنه تتصاعد حده الاشتباكات لنرى بعد
قليل بعد سبع دقائق اذا ما كان الطرفي
النزاع سيلتزمون بهذه الهدنه ام انها
ستكون
متقطعه ثم تشتد حده الاشتباكات بعد ساعات
من الهدنه وطبعا بالامس تبعنا حرب
البيانات بين الطرفين بعدما دخلنا
بالتوقيت المعلن للهدنه والتي كان قد وافق
عليها الطرفين بعد وساطه امريكيه ووساطه
يعني اقليميه واماميه بضروره تطبيق هدنه
بين الطرفين لفتح مسار انساني ومسار سياسي
طبعا بين الطرفين السماع الى الصوت
الطبيعي واعود مشاهدينا
اعود اليك استاذ اسامه نحن امام ست دقائق
قبل الهدنه المعلنه في حال لم يلتزم
الطرفان كما بالامس ماذا يعني ذلك على
الواقع الانساني السوداني 24 ساعه جديده
من الحصار من عدم وجود
امدادات انسانيه على المستوى الصحي على
مستوى الغذائي وغيره
لا نامل انه في هذه الهدنه يكون في اتفاق
واضح يعني يساعد في
او رفض او تزويد المستشفيات
بالمواد الطبيه اللازمه لاداء مهام
الطبيعيه نحن بنتمنى كلنا بنتمنى هذه
الامنيه وتغطي كل المساحه بتاعه
المستشفيات والمكاح الافقيه بتاعه ولايه
الخرطوم نتمنى انه يحصل كده وفيديوهات
كثيره مستعده تدعم كلنا عندنا يعني
عندنا اشياء ممكن ندعم بها حتى اللجنه
الدوليه والاتحاد الدولي بس
الهدنه دي تكون واضحه والمسارات تكون امنه
ان شاء الله اعود اليك سيده ايلونه ايضا
قبل خمس دقائق من هذه
الهدنه المعلنه اذا لم يلتزم الطرفان بها
كما بالامس ماذا يعني ذلك على الواقع
الصحي والانسان داخل الخرطوم
تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه
للمواطنين في الخرطوم وللمستشفيات
والعاملين في القطاع الصحي
لاتواقم الطبيه وللشعب الذي كان يمر في
تحمل هذه المعاناه منذ عده ايام في تلك
الظروف الصعبه دون كهرباء ودون مياه ودون
ومع نفاد المواد الغذائيه وخوف ودعر بين
الاطفال
واناس كثر عالقون في اماكن مختلفه لا
يستطيعون الخروج وبالنسبه لنا كمنظمات
انسانيه وكعامل متطوعين في الهلال الاحمر
والاطباء فالامر محبط جدا لنا لاننا هذا
عملنا هو ان نقدم تلك المساعدات الانسانيه
والاستجابه لهذا الوضع لكننا عالقون
ومكتوب في الايادي ولا نستطيع فعل اي شيء
البته اليوم بالخرطوم المستشفي ات
بشده الى الامدادات
للحياه تفتقر الى يعني الامدادات الاوليه
والاسعافات الاوليه اللازمه وكل يعني
المستلزمات الطبيه الاساسيه وطبعا انقطاع
الكهرباء وانقطاع المياه فاقم الوضع اكثر
هذا ماذا يعني على مستوى ارقام الخسائر
البشريه في الساعات المقبله
هل تسمعينني
بانه في حاله عدم تلقطيهم المساعدات
الانسانيه فسوف يلقون حذفهم فكلما طال امد
هذا القتال
لاصبحت الفتره الزمنيه
لحاجه الناس لهذه المساعدات الطبيه وعدم
استلامها فهذا يعني ان
عدد الوفيات الماساويه سوف تستمر في
الارتفاع هذا ما يعنيه الامر
ساعود اليك استاذ اسامه سؤال اخير اليوم
نحن امام طرفي نزاع لا يحترمون على الاقل
المواثيق الدوليه للحروب يعني الاعراف
الانسانيه للحروب بظل يعني قصف عشوائي ان
كان للمستشفيات وان كان للاماكن التي يجب
ان لا يقترب منها ماذا يعني ذلك اذا في
حال لم يتم التواصل معهم
ليس فقط هدنه وانما احترام لقواعد
الاشتباك على الارض
احنا دائما بنامل نحن في
الجمعيات الهلال الاحمر السوداني او
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر بشكل عام ما
بننتهم جهه من الجهات ولا نلقي اللوم على
جهه من الجهات لانه من المصلحه العامه
نحسب الناشد الجهات انها تاكد التزامه
بنصوص القانون الدولي الانساني
وعلى انه في النهايه تكون المصلحه لكل
الناس والناس مع تعاني فنحن بنامل انه
الهدنه تكون الهدنه كامله تكون في مسارات
امنه واضحه عشان يتم تشد على المنظمات
ونحن نشتغل شغلنا في مساعده ضحايا في
مساعده المسلح نعم ابقى
مشاهدينا التغطيه مستمره بعد قليل مع
الزميله منتهى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات